je suis avide et alec je suis un type
plasticienne de livres
on la nuit des musées je vais faire une
projection vidéo
mais au fait ça va être deux projections
vidéo sur la façade du musée léon dierx
[Musique]
ce furent là moi je me fais une double
projection j'ai imaginé à une histoire
où deux personnes se parlent à travers
la chanson de différents styles de
chansons
le séga et l'opéra plus chanter à
travers le maloya et ensemble avec ça
les images de la réunion bien d'ici où
il ya des gens d'ici qui ont participé à
cette à la réaction de cette vidéo ça ça
me rend très joyeux je suis extrêmement
fier aux puces d'abord cette possibilité
de montrer mon travail sur la façade du
musée les rosières c'est un beau lieu
mais en même temps ça va être un grand
événement parce que les musées seront
ouverts et à gratuitement et c'est
l'occasion des gens pour les gens de
venir est vraiment voir
il a apprécié rentrer dans l'ambiance et
voir ce que les antilles sont à offrir
c'est quelque chose de très intéressant
et très fort la nuit des musées
parce que nous même au niveau du
département on a un patrimoine muséal et
la nuit des musées
eva ça sert aussi à éclairer nos musées
et je dirais que cette année
particulièrement il ya un éclairage
fabuleux est particulier puisque c'est
aussi la nuit des musées la nuit
numérique et il y aura aussi des
projections de lumières et d'image sur
le musée léon dierx sur des musées le
musée d'histoire naturelle et ça va être
le plus pour cette année 2010 est
[Musique]